die ganz große Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
hat kein Vertrauen in diese Regierung
sie hat keinen Kanzler der irgendwie
führt ich hab wir haben heute glaube ich
den 11 Januar oder 12 was immer der
Kanzler ich habe bis heute ich habe den
dieses Jahr noch gar nicht wahrgenommen
also dieses Land ist in
Unruhe und ich habe ihn dieses Jahr noch
gar nichts wahrgenommen seine seine
Neujahrsansprache die hätte man in jedem
anderen Jahr der letzten 20 Jahre auch
abspielen können die hat überhaupt
nichtsers aber wir sind ja vielleicht
auch in der mag doch sein aber ich rede
jetzt darüber wie die Zeit im Land
gerade jetzt ist und dieses Land braucht
eines mehr denn je das ist politische
Führung eine Regierung die eine Idee
davon hat wo sie mit diesem Land in der
Krise und auch in diesem Jahrzehnt hin
will stattdessen gibt's jeden Tag Streit
und einen Kanzler der nicht zu sehen
ist